Hello Freak bitches.
Keep in mind that these narratives of Ford by public opinion,
right,
this isn't the studio is trying to make the public,
um,
force feed the public like gender roles and you know,
whatever this is the public saying.
I like that.
I don't like that.
So the studios are responding to the questionnaires that these researchers give
out.
So one of the really interesting things,
and this is totally inflammatory,
but the,
the role of the person defending like physically,
physically defending the community when they try to put a woman in that role,
people have a problem with it.
And,
and,
and frankly,
often women have a problem with it.
Like it's real,
it's really,
really interesting.
And women are just as important as men in a crisis or in anything,
right?
But the,
what the public seems to want is the guy with the sword and the woman with the
bandage,
you know,
or,
or with the sort of reassuring,
you know,
like he gets divided like that and it's not,
again,
it's not the studios forcing something on people.
Is it the people watching these films saying just voting on what they,
the narrative that they'd like best.
But the,
the other character that I thought was really hilarious,
there's often that there is eight,
an estranged husband who's betrayed his wife and family in some way.
He's on the outs,
right?
Uh,
uh,
with his family and his,
with his wife.
And then the crisis happens.
The martians invade the floodwaters rise,
whatever it is,
and he comes to the rescue and does the right thing and saves his wife and
family and maybe even the wife's new boyfriend.
I mean,
he,
Keven could have gotten to that stage,
right?
And because he does the right thing,
she takes them back.
God,
it's funny,
man.
It's really just playing out these ancient archetypes.
It's exactly what it's doing.
I mean,
they,
those storylines resonate because they're ancient and because those,
those roles in society helped us survive.
And then it dawned on me,
wait a second.
Stamets you're in the tallest tree on the tallest hill for miles in the middle
of a lightning storm.
This is not the best place to be.
And so I realize I could be killed up here.
Suddenly I had a reality rush.
Like,
you know,
you're,
you could turn into a god.
Imagine Comics Kaia 20 grams of mushrooms hugging a tree.
The lightning comes and hits you and Paul,
maybe you were the savior.
Maybe you need to get back to that tree.
Maybe you're the chosen one.
So I,
I was,
you know,
I,
it was an incredibly spiritual and wonderful experience,
but I also had the fear and just comes,
comes with it.
The Hero's journey,
you know,
you always have the dark side.
He always have,
not just the light side,
but it's counterbalanced with the dark side.
Then I realized,
oh my gosh,
I'm gonna,
I could die up here.
And I said,
well,
I don't die.
Stamets which,
where are your issues?
This,
this gets something out of this experience.
I said,
this stuttering habit is ridiculous and I,
I'm not stupid.
And I saw,
I said to myself,
stop stuttering now.
Stop Stuttering now.
I said that dozens,
hundreds of times over and over and over.
And fortunately the storms went past and held onto the tree and soaking wet.
I came out of the tree and lock back to where I was living.
And then the next day I got up,
I didn't see anybody and I was walking along on this path and a sidewalk and
there's a lady that I really liked a lot.
And uh,
but she was always attracted to the super self assured jocks and things like
that.
She was actually very kind and sweet,
but I didn't want to stare at her in the eyes because I would stutter.
And it's humiliating for us.
So the more humiliating us stutterers feel,
the more we stutter.
And so it's a really slippery slope.
And so I would avoid eye contact.
And so for the first time she walked towards him,
he says,
Good Morning Paul,
how are you?
She was always so nice to me and I was terrified because I'd embarrass myself.
And I looked at her straight in the eyes and I said,
I'm doing fine.
How are you?
And I stopped stuttering in one day.
Whoa.
And this speaks to now what was been medically proven is that we can reset the
neurology of the human brain through neurogenesis.
What do you think is a real no bullshit achievable time for you at full
marathon?
Full Marathon.
Jamie,
you got to help me.
You run for 45 to a little over two.
It'd be a pretty good full marathons,
full nights.
Five fives as it got five has to be a good mark because after that three hour
mark or even doing the half,
you're going to hit a real tough wall,
but you also will be running with a pace group the whole time,
which helps and I'll do anything.
I have to go with them no matter what.
I have to go with that.
Five hours,
five hours.
That's hilarious.
I don't even know what I'm saying.
I'm thinking about draining my bank account to bet you hold on Joe.
Five hours.
What are we doing here?
I like this like do you think he could do it for five hours?
Yeah.
Hey,
hold on.
I'm looking at it saying this.
Wow.
Take an Ra and I could make some serious money on,
let's get up,
let's get it.
Let's get a course that we're talking cause we're not going to,
can't do one in Colorado.
Obviously I want to,
I want to Boston,
it'll keep you a lot to say like five hours.
You would have to really prepare.
No,
he's willing.
I want to see what he's at now shape right now.
So wait,
he,
you'd have to really prepare to do five hours.
I think you could do it.
I'm not saying you couldn't do it.
If we're not giving you a year,
idiot,
fuck,
you're going to do it.
What's the next marathon?
What's the,
what,
what city are they going to be in?
San Diego,
La [inaudible]
you know,
do you know the story of Viagara and how that was developed was,
um,
some sort of a blood pressure medication,
correct.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
so they found like,
okay,
this isn't working very well for what we designed it for,
but,
but it's got some pretty interesting effects.
And so,
but they knew it wasn't enough to just then go out there and start selling it
for two guys to say,
hey,
here's a drug that will help make you perform better.
Right.
Bedroom.
That wasn't enough.
What they had to do was create a disease that it could be prescribed for because
that's,
and then,
and then you know how they did that,
they hired an advertising agency and the ad agency came up with the term
erectile dysfunction.
No Way.
And created this.
Absolutely.
It's publicly available information named a disease.
This is not the only case where this has happened.
So they create this disease category and then they'd get it out into the world
and they advertise it to people and to doctors and so all of a sudden people are
going in with the magazine.
They're like,
this is me.
I have erectile dysfunction.
And I know now there's a drug called Viagara that I need because I have erectile
dysfunction.
And the doctor has seen the,
they have their own brochure.
Yeah.
They pull out their brochure and it says erectile dysfunction.
Here are the signs and symptoms.
Okay.
Check,
check,
check.
Yes.
This patient's got erectile Ed.
So here's the drug.
Oh,
is it legal for an advertising agency to name a disorder?
Well,
I'll tell you that it's illegal in every single country in the world except for
New Zealand and the United States to advertise drugs to consumers.
Please New Zealand be the first strange.
Please turn around,
make us look terrible at first because this is the,
this is the result.
This is the result of allowing drugs to be advertised is that you get
advertising agencies creating conditions that then required drugs to be treated.
And this,
you know,
this is like the air I'm hanging out with Dennis.
I mean,
look at Dennis this size compared to Shaq.
If you didn't know it was Dennis Rodman,
it was just some,
you know NBA Scrub,
right?
You would think there's no way that guy's going to guard him one on one.
Especially Shaq in his prime there.
There's no way.
Yeah,
it's Rodman is a crazy guy.
That's interesting.
Speaking crazy.
Can I tell you a funny story?
He got a good story.
Yeah.
So used to hang out a lot with Dennis,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
hadn't seen him for years.
Was that a restaurant?
Chicago not too long ago.
And um,
and somebody said,
oh,
you guys are friends with Dennis,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
he's upstairs.
Oh really?
We go upstairs.
Dennis is crying.
Oh my God.
I miss you guys.
And me and my buddy were hanging out with them telling old stories,
you know,
seven or eight years,
haven't seen him.
This is great.
Like,
uh,
when you see a buddy you really love and it's really affectionate and Dennis is
one of those people at some point he just gets up and he wanders away.
I think he's going to take a piss.
Okay.
About 10 minutes goes by,
I say to the waitress.
To Dennis leave.
Yeah,
he left.
Okay.
I just figured he's gone.
It's just the way he is.
Right.
They wouldn't even say goodbye.
Just gone.
I get up the next morning,
I the television,
Dennis Rodman's in North Korea.
Okay.
I,
by the way,
I spend an hour and a half with them.
He didn't say anything.
We go about going to North Korea,
right?
So I turn on the television,
it's like very controversial.
Dennis Rodman's in North Korea.
So I text my buddy and I say,
have you seen the news?
No.
What?
I say,
turn on the television.
And he said,
what channel?
I said,
it doesn't matter.
And two minutes goes by,
Holy Fuck.
Because he went through the same thing,
you know?
Okay.